und im studio begrüße ich jetzt den
bundesdeutschen außenminister guten
abend heiko maas kalorien aber hat sich
das einmal aktuelle präsident erdogan
zitieren er sagt über die kurden wir
werden die köpfe der rebell zerquetschen
und über sie wir haben es gerade gehört
sie nennt er einen politischen
dilettanten bei aller diplomatischen
zurückhaltung was sagt man einen solchen
nato-partner ehrlich gesagt eigentlich
gar nix ist es mir persönlich auch hoch
wie breit im ergebnis ist es mir
allerdings lieber herr erdogan schießt
mit worten als mit raketen
wenn wir uns darauf verständigen können
kann alles gerne weiter beschimpft ja
das ist der grund weshalb wir innerhalb
der europäischen union wir uns ja sehr
schnell auf der ebene der außenminister
entschieden haben keine waffen mehr in
die türkei zu exportieren
das tun wir im übrigen schon seit
einigen jahren nämlich seitdem die
türkei schon in afrika einmarschierte
und portieren weiter nur vielleicht
nicht die waffen die er in syrien
einsetzen exportieren überhaupt nichts
mehr wir haben in der vergangenheit
lediglich noch noch gerätschaft
geliefert um etwa end - maßnahmen
durchzuführen oder an die türkische
marine also kein kriegsgerät das noch
auch nur im ansatz in syrien zum einsatz
kommen könnte und das wird auch so
bleiben sie sind nicht nur aus minister
sondern auch jurist ist sein angriff
völkerrechtswidrig ein klares wort nach
all dem was wir wissen und nach all dem
was sie die türkei selber als als
rechtsgrundlage angeführt hat können wir
das nicht teilen wir glauben nicht dass
ein angriff auf kurdische einheiten oder
kurdische milizen völkerrechtlich
legitimiert ist oder auch legitim das
ist ein völkerrechts bruch der wenn es
keine grundlage im völkerrecht recht
gibt für eine solche invasion dann ist
ja auch nicht im einklang mit dem
völkerrecht ihr fraktionsvorsitzender
mit ziemlich hat jetzt gesagt es ist ein
wie sie auch in rechts
völkerrechtswidriger angriffskrieg und
er geht weiter er sagt das müsste
konsequenzen vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof haben einverstanden
das wird glaube ich erst in den
kommenden wochen zu klären sein
im moment haben wir ja gott sei dank
eine waffenruhe die auch einigermaßen
hält und wir werden alles daran setzen
dass diese waffenruhe nicht nur fünf
tage hält sondern dass sie länger
andauert und damit diese innovation
zunächst einmal gestoppt wird und dann
muss man mit der türkei auch reden und
dafür brauchen wir den dialog wie es
dort weitergehen kann wir sind damit
nicht einverstanden weil sie noch nicht
damit einverstanden dass syrische
bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge die jetzt in der
türkei sind dann auf die art und weise
nach syrien geschickt werden nach
nordost syrien in die sicherheitszone
möglicherweise gegen ihren willen das
sind alles themen mit denen muss man mit
der türkei reden natürlich im
zusammenhang mit dem flüchtlings
abkommen denn wir werden nicht die
zahlen für dinge die nach unserer
auffassung nicht legitim oder legal sind
sie sind jetzt auf den weg ins
kanzleramt zum koalitionsausschuss wir
haben eben beitrag eben gesehen die
notwendige einstimmigkeit in europa
fehlt welche maßnahmen liegen denn im
kanzleramt auf dem tisch also erstmal
für die einstimmigkeit nicht sondern sie
ist vorhanden
wir haben uns alle etwas an und man hat
alle beschlüsse mitgetragen ungarn hat
auch den beschluss mitgetragen bei den
außenministern keine waffen mehr in die
türkei zu exportieren und wir haben sehr
deutlich gesagt dass wir uns weitere
maßnahmen dazu können auch
wirtschaftssanktionen gehören offenheit
und deshalb wollen wir jetzt abwarten
was nach dieser waffenruhe geschieht wie
sich die türkei weiter verhalten wird
und das ist es dann muss das nicht das
letzte wort gewesen sein schauen wir auf
die wirtschaftsmaßnahmen bisher kann die
türkei zollfrei in die eu exportieren
wir zahlen milliardenschwere hermes
kredite während das maßnahmen die sie im
auge haben damals kredite bürgschaften
sind in der vergangenheit schon mal
zumindest gedeckelt worden
das wäre nicht neu aber damit werden wir
uns auseinandersetzen wenn es soweit ist
und das wollen wir vor allen dingen tun
wird unseren europäischen partnern denn
es nützt wenig wenn einer in europa das
tut oder sanktionen ausspricht und dann
andere einspringen also auch da müssen
wir in europa mit einer stimme kurze
antwort zum schluss sollte syrien jetzt
umgekehrt die türkei angreifen wäre das
der nato bündnisfall ganz kurz
das käme darauf an in welcher form das
geschieht aber das kann ich mir beim
besten willen nicht vorstellen dass das
den bündnisfall der nato auslösen würde
zumindest dann gehen für das gespräch
gerne